so let's talk about healthcare again the
key issue particularly right now
yesterday I reminded you how for years
under President Obama Republicans voted
dozens of times to repeal the Affordable
Care Act in the house they knew it
wouldn't succeed because even if it
passed the Senate even if it passed the
House President Obama would have vetoed
it Donald Trump ran on repeal and
replace they get into power they control
the house they control the Senate they
control the White House and then they
can't agree on a repeal and replace Bill
Donald Trump initially blames
obstruction as Democrats even though it
was Republicans that wouldn't even get
on board then most recently over the
fourth of July weekend Donald Trump
suggests we'll just repeal it we'll deal
with the replacement later of course
that would lead to 32 million people
losing health insurance as I told you
yesterday and now they're back to their
old faithful strategy when you can't
make progress you blame Obama or in this
clique case you blame Hillary Clinton
and other Democrats this was a tweet
that was put out by the Republican
Twitter account quoting Hillary Clinton
we've got to fix what's broken and then
saying where's your plan Hillary Clinton
of course this is July of 2017
what does Hillary Clinton's plan matter
and this was part of a broader ad
criticizing Democrats about Obama care
take a look at this and my view is that
the Affordable Care Act has problems
deductibles are too high co-payments are
too high we have to address that I've
been saying we've got to fix what's
broken I'm willing to look at replacing
repairing doing anything that we can to
make it better for years now we have
said we need to make improvements to the
Affordable Care Act to Obama care there
are problems with ACA so you've got this
crazy system where all the 725 million
more people health health care and then
the people are at watch the coop in six
years
wind up with their premiums double than
their coverage cut in half it's the
craziest thing in the world the onus
also on Democrats what are they going to
do to fix the existing one right and
they haven't offered any solutions would
be smart for Democrats to offer their
own alternatives their own fixes your
llama tires now and try to vote very
good points that's a very good point
there seems to have been this resistance
for Democrats to get more involved do
you share part of the burden for a
failure to improve Obamacare
why aren't you working to fix this
rather than just saying no right okay so
basically the idea is we're going to
single out Democrats who admitted there
were problems with the Affordable Care
Act and by the way who wouldn't admit
that and then we're going to blame them
for not having the solutions to fix it
the problem is Hillary Clinton didn't
run on repealing it you did Donald and
the problem also is that it's now not
the ability Democrats couldn't possibly
fix it now because they're not in
control of any branch of government or
either house of Congress the problem
also is that Hillary Clinton did have a
lifted list of changes that would have
moved Obamacare to the left
whereas Republicans want to destroy
health care from the inside out with the
American Health Care Act Hillary
Clinton's plan was slightly to the left
of the Affordable Care Act now I've told
you ACA is pretty damn right-wing there
this is nothing to cheer about and I'm
not going to start ripping my clothes
off and burning them in celebration of
Hillary Clinton's plan but she had a
plan that would have been slightly
better than the Affordable Health Care
Act she wanted to use the government
negotiating power to bring down
prescription drug prices Donald Trump
actually campaigned on doing the exact
same thing got elected had a meeting
with big pharma lobbyists came out of
the meeting all of a sudden no longer
has the plans to do that negotiating she
was looking at some new tax credits to
offset some out-of-pocket costs for
people with severe medical problems that
would have increased access to care it
also would have added about two hundred
and fifty billion dollars in costs over
ten years it would have been paid for
though by higher income taxes on the
very wealthy
which most Americans actually do support
she still would have kept our depraved
disgusting dilapidated for-profit health
insurance system but it would have been
a slight tweak to the left the point is
Hillary is not the problem Republicans
right now have no one to blame but
themselves and this was one of the most
disingenuous political ads that I've
ever seen before because if you watch
any cable news you know what the
standard democratic talking point is on
this yeah you they concede that you know
there are certainly some problems with
the Affordable Care Act but the solution
isn't to go further right it's to go
further less that's why we knew that
this would happen with health care if
Donald Trump won and it is happening
that now the Republicans have to face
the reality of doing what they promised
on health care but the shocking part is
that the supporters don't seem to care
that you can't do what Trump promised
you can't move to the right from where
we are and reduce costs increase quality
of care and increase access to care you
just can't do it
and the Republican Trump supporters
don't seem to care they seem to be not
fatigued by the constant excuses from
the right about why health care isn't
fixed yet and now Republicans are
capitalizing on Trump estate for Hillary
Clinton by saying hey let's now blame
Hillary Clinton for the problem that
we're in today it's pathetic and the
saddest part is that some of these low
information Trump fists are falling for
it today's episode of the david pakman
show is made possible in part by Warby
Parker eyeglasses Warby Parker recently
did the right thing and ditched
advertising on right-wing conspiracy
website Breitbart pulling their ads off
and you can get the free five-day home
Tryon from Warby Parker check out their
glasses I use them when I'm not wearing
contact lenses I started with the free
at-home trial they send you five pairs
of glasses you see which ones you like
you send them back and whichever one you
pick they will put your prescription in
- I like this because I can actually
show the glasses to other people and not
have to just decide on the spot like in
an eyeglass store the eyeglass industry
is controlled by very few corporations
that
the price is very very high even over
$300 for prescription glasses with Warby
Parker they started just 95 bucks mine
cost that including lenses and for every
pair sold they give a pair to someone in
need so to try to five pairs and support
the David Pakman show go to Warby Parker
trial comm /t DPS